へいへい
あああああ
写真家な判定をする日と申します最初に私が地球温暖化について関心を持ったのは
2002年頃に南極のロースターな氷に亀裂が入って関東平野ほどの面積の表彰を入手
したという記事を読んだ時でしたはっきり言ってその時にはこの自体それほど深刻に
受け止めていたわけでありません
んそれから15年もたった2016年の違
4月から2月にかけてこのらーセンターが氷で撮影したんですけれども
書とはいえですねこの辺りっていうのはもうこのここから崩れをした巨大な協調がです
ね
舞木たる所にありましてそれらがいわゆる迷うデータアイスバーグっていうか表なん
ですね
それの長が代表だがいたるところで見受けられました
ここもはペニー長いますけどこんな状態ですね
これはの通常はですね北極とかこういう場所へ行ってると狼られるこういったんだいた
流氷の合理なんですけれどもこういうものこういうものはこれだけ数があるとほとんど
見たことがありません
つまりそれだけ事態が深刻っていうことですねこれだけ氷がこれだけ広大な効力釣りを
しているっていうかな
この写真はですねこれはの評弾でありませんこれを何曲タイミングです
でここはの岩盤がですね黒い土なので一旦こんな風に行きとが氷が溶けてしまうともう
この黒い
したのガンバは黒いために対応熱をバンバン吸収してしまってそれをそのためにも溶解
速度が加速度的に変わってくる速くなってくるっていうことです
それを見せている写真ですこれはあの2017年の11月にですね
あのサウジ10時あって場所設定したんですけどこのサービス業者っていう場所は南極
のたより根のあのな曲の中では比較的行為とか抜きやすく無い場所なんで
そんな意味ではこのキングペンギンのですねそうなってるん
ですけれどもそれにしてもですねちょうどこの時期はの
行動でも北極と比べて南極の氷がむしろ増えてるんじゃないかみたいな報道もあったん
ですが実際私ここを歌ってみた時に行きを見ることはほとんど無かったし氷も全くあり
ませんでした
ここの辺りはですねあの温暖な場所なので
割方この辺でだいたい南から来た氷山が溶け出してそれにくっついてた
タイロン植物プランクトンが大きな置屋美代子を呼び込んでですねそのうちは見送って
この近所10人だとかゾウアザラシだとか
オットセイだとかアガシだとかそういったものが
もう今爆発的に増えているという話
でもちろん言うまでもなくあの
co2排出国がもあっ通りを北半球は方が集まりその北限ですねその北極の方がはるか
に事態は深刻です
これはあの私が最初に実は2回行ってるんですけれども
なんで議会撮影になっちゃったかと言うと実はこの最初に行った時にですね
もうこれだけもうキリング状態がすごくてこれはどういうことかというともう回目
ポイントは上昇しきっちゃってるので言ってしまえば自分の色棒線が例えば煮え立つ鍋
の中にいるようなそんな状態なん
ん
それでそんな状態だったもんでもう大薄根事態が動くことの柱挑戦な状態で
だからこんなもと好まざるとにかかわらずここはもう1回行かざるを得なくなっちゃっ
たっていうそういう状況だったんですその時の1回目の的ってのは大体今までご覧
いただいているのはこんなに状況ですよねそれが結局この後にここでここまでがそう
ですここがいいか女なんです
2度目ここからわずか2週間後です
その時にはもうこんな状態ですでこれはかなりシリアスで通常前に出ても写真た皆さん
ご覧になったと思うんですけど
通常棚氷で9ゴールが崩れる時っていうのはその人にまだ氷がありますつまり
陸地があってもそこから何百メートルも交流があるんですねこの状態ってもう土がで
今で剥がれおっしゃってるんですそのぐらいモダンかつどんいるってことなんですねで
これはまだいいほうなんですけれど誰でもこの次の写真
これはもう表が溶け出して皮ができています
巨大な川ですこれもう幅与う1キロぐらいありますけれどもこれ全部と気がします
次ですねこれ3穴これも地肌午後1時シャツ
氷まったくないんです次はこの写真はですね
あの欧州圏の細胞来たーー北 u 8 u 1です
フィリップそうやって場所なんですけれどもこうから北極点までは540万円し離れて
いません
東京広島こともないです
それでこの状態です
しかもこれ5年前です
でこの時にはやっぱり ki 所に行ったヒアリング
それがですね2週間もこれです
これですでこのころはまだいいんです初期の頃だったので僕も舞う
しろくま超えてるんですけど可哀想な子の次ですね
もうこんなです
最初種類額と思いましたん
こんな状況になっちゃうんです結局この子たちはアザラシを捕食してますからあのあれ
なんですけど結局も
アザラシ食えなくなったらを待って流しだけなんですよ死ぬしかないんですけど来た
じゃあで例えばこんななかなかにはですねこいつみたいにあの鳥の卵を狙ってあのが
てぃるんですけど結局この
桑名市っていうの交流が歩くためのものだって言わんがある子じゃないんですね
だからしゅっちゅうこっか落ちてですね死んでるクマがいっぱいますそれとか中には
ですね自分えら春がでっかいこのセイウチですねこれを狙ってくれてもいるんですよ
大概はこの木場で突き刺されて殺されていますそれが今の補強板現場ですね
ここはですねあの
ナミビアのファブガーって言うところの流域にある
砂漠地帯に住んでいるぞーなんですけどなんで砂漠に土蔵いるんだからと不思議もある
かもしれないけど実はここは浪費と感じがはっきりしていてウキの間にあの地下に
ため込んだ大量の水があって
であるいはその植物なんかもそこに深く根を下ろしていますからそういったもの
を求めて憎悪ずっと移動を繰り返すわけですでこれはあの親がですね
幼女母親ぞありおばあちゃんどうっていうのはもうちょっと無理を引き連れてそれでも
ここに水があるんだよここに餌があるんだよと教えていくわけですね
ですからそれからわかっているのでそこ行くんですけれども
そんな状態ですでただ者のオスのゾウっていうのは単独で行動するのでこんな状況です
けど何とこんな砂漠に生活しています
だけどあのう
そうやって来なそういったことの理由ですねで次ですね
ところがですねこれを多分それを信じてこの小僧もついここはについてきたんだと思う
んです
さあ目的地に着いたと思ってたんだけどもうここは水がないんですねつまりどういう
ことかと
気候温暖化っていうのは局地的な豪雨とそれから局地的な感想っていうのをふくさに
起きるんです実際ここのナミビアでもですね北部とか隣のアングラーとの境界線という
のは毎年洪水怒ってるんですよ
だけどこの地域ってのはここ数年間あの
こうってのは全く確認されませんたぶんこのことをそれを子があってここへ来てビズ
述べると思ったんだけどもここで諦めてしまったんだと思いますおそらく死んだと思い
ます
でこれはですねあのへ当社というところを撮影したものなんですけど元々あのこういう
動物はこういった経験では観光資源なのでそこでは人工的な水を作ってるんですけれど
もその水場でですねあの一番問題になったのはここで起こっている陶酔ですね水を盗む
ということです
これはの木ケーキをこの近くにですねあの
畑をつくってそこから自分たちのその考えを誘導するためにですねこれからどんどん水
を盗んでいっちゃうんですよ
でそういったこともある家をこういうのって経済格差ですねほんといい一部の人間の
強欲だけれどいうのが引き起こしてるんだってこういった結果を変える波があったら
こういうこと
米地球温暖化を増長し結局それはアマゾンの森林破壊とかあるいはもう
インドネシアのパームラーバン畑だとかそういったところいろんな問題評価してます
けれどもやっぱりこういう心に入ると良くないと思いますよ
アメリカなんか成人黒それでもまだ後進国が多いんですがそれでも税金国でもアメリカ
のマリファナバターでとか
スペインの一部はたけど同じような事やっててこっちを持った悪質でみんなお金払って
買ってちゃんと機
キレイにしている水を増税してますからもっと事態は深刻です
まああの幸いこの原稿書いてるわねですねあの売電大統領の誕生は魔法か縁になりまし
たから
おそらくあれば自分でも前月より尿とで復帰すると言ってますし
ですが政権と最も2050年までカー母乳たら例えば明言しています
これ歓迎することには聞こえるんですけどでも明確な政策ってのはほとん
で示さんじゃないですね例えば自動車を全部言い化するって言ってやってますけど
現代でも普通のその異常者のかなくて現在の発電量でもおったなぁ足らなくなってます
原子力発電放棄しましたからその部分を要するに火力発電でその不足分を補っているの
がないけど上積みされてくる新たなボーダーでどうやって賄っていくのかということ
ですね
例えば補充議員などを準備される者たちどこへその企業絶級しますから
昔いっぱいソーラーの会社なんかもありましたけどバタバタバタバタ撤退しましたよね
こんなことがあったりとかあるいはこれで3銀閣まで行くよ一体ソーラーパネルどこだ
てるんだって話ですね韓国なんかではそういった山林の中に無理をしてソーラーパネル
つくりましたけれど結局それが豪雨によってダイエット
野菜が引き起こしたりだとかカラーのアメリカでやっぱり臨月させたのは当たる風力
発電のオール立ててるんですけれどここには大量の渡り鳥が衝突してまた新たなもんで
結構しています
あまりにも広急ぎすぎて過剰中でお聴きのスイッチっていうのは本当にあの逆に言えば
その
こういったことによって新たなたりを我々が持っている海産資源海洋自然とかですね
あるいはそのこれからまあホラーが終わればまた戻ってくるかもしれないインバウンド
んだための我々クリアのんですの観光資源たら自然景観の破壊にもつながりかねませ
んかですからそれはもうちょっとシャレなねーなーと思ってるんですけど
まあだから非常にしても今当面は現実的なコストを考えれば
を笑楽は稼ぎ裏によりと家とか一時的なものだ今日対策名を捨てて
例えば水素発電とかそういった方向に待つしかないのかなぁなんて個人的には思って
いるんですけれども
まあどういう国早くそういうものが冠されてもらいたいなと思っています
ね
産業革命時代前から平均気温が2度あり上がるとし前菜が来はて負のスパイラルでもっ
てさらに増長されてもう止めようがなくなるって言われてます
性格して記録されている最高気温ちっていうのはここ10年日本とすべて集中していて
その深刻さは米国の西海岸とかアマゾンなパターンがあるとかオーストラリアとかで
発生して号機欲しいに管財
あるいはは杭にも頻発してますけど超大型台風とか州厨房
シベリアの永久凍土妖怪による莫大な量の co2を含んだメタンと頭に腐敗車動物の
違いから生ずる猛毒の炭素絹
バック麻生氏とかそういった形でメーカーなってますもうこれ以上です女性2被安打
52年まで濃厚か
ウチは体力が中央北部のように限られるようになって10億人以上の人々が移住を余儀
なくされます
まあだと上田市の南極の行為っていうのは世界の湾岸都市のすべてを水分させ工事受け
た地域ではもう大量に発生と態度の彼はですね
直熱デング熱マラリアといったこれまで熱帯地方に埋められた感染症がパンデミックを
引くをして
人間はもうそれだけではなくもうたぶんそこで命の洗濯も取られると思う
その上で人間は暑さのためクスもできなくなるしおそらく電気も止まりますっていうの
冷却性もなくなりますから
行成によって大杉も見えますからおそらく的は営業総なくなる
そうなるとマーケットからすべて水とか食べ物も消えされますアメリカ3大組だと暴動
起こるかもしれませんあるいは逆脱毛これでしょ
そんな状態になると思いますもうそういうふうに私たちはもう妨害してる時間は残され
てないんですねだからもう科学と本当にあの局地的にこう散発しているエビデンスです
ねこういったものを無視してただ
今日は実は回ってですねああこれは対岸の火事涙にどこ行って呑気に構え時もあるよ
どうなったかったら割れるコーナーでも経験していると思います
既にお亡くなりになったかでも大生ないかだけどそれでもコロナはね
ワクチンとか何中学ができるかもしれません
だけで地球環境いった配管されたらもうやり直しはきかないんですよ
人間これまであまりも方前に強引
こう経済政策を追求してきましたけれども今後は対象の後痛みを伴ってしてもですね
やっぱり加速的速やかにほんと世界が1協力して同時にこれを進めないと
でもできるだけ早くやらないとで貧困国に対した方は我は例えば支援するとかで協力を
しながらですね世界を一つにな
って同時にこれを
今すぐ行いならないとですねおそらく2050年までに我々の未来はもうなくなります
実際20世紀にわかっている地球温暖化ンソクの4倍で20隻を進んでいると言われて
いますそういうデータも出ています
以上ですありがとうございました